David how are you I don't want to fight
you doing brother when's the last time
you hit somebody I mean really hit
somebody last night right Jojo I tota
usually football my son team and there's
nine years for ball in Oconee County and
what am i running back keep swinging the
ball down you know you can't swing the
ball in your chance you know yes I I
tell you fumble so i told my was it i
got a hand shield i said next time you
keep swinging the football and knock you
out with a hand shield so i'm knocking
out a couple nights are a couple times
last night at the hand shield when's the
last time you got hit um how am I Sun
hits me all the time he he thinks I'm a
tackling dummy so I didn't think it fit
he's playing he's learning football
learned how to wrap up and he'll try me
occasionally I gotta I gotta put him in
his place a little bit but it's Jack
it's fun playing playing football with
him so all right let me start with a
headlines if LSU beats auburn what
happens uh that's miles still have a job
I think I think he'd still be in Baton
Rouge now I think this is one of those
things where it felt like it was going
to happen at some point it's just how it
felt last year with the the way it ended
up and the way they left him twisting in
the wind was I didn't agree with father
well if you're going to fire somebody
and you're gonna you know let somebody
go if you're thinking about it it
doesn't need to be a public thing it
doesn't that that's not the way you
handle your business i don't think and I
don't like that but I think at some
point after the wisconsin game the
writing was on the wall if you continued
to lose games now listen if you win
games you know that works and you win
games all the sudden you're a hero and
everybody loves you again and you have a
job and everybody's excited it feels
like LSU wanted to fire Les Miles now
just so he couldn't win the job back you
know all of a sudden win five in a row
and then you can't fire him after that
do you think that that was probably they
were looking for that jumping off spot
Wow again something's missing dan
because I'll tell you this and this is
just being completely honest when I was
doing my final four before the season
LSU is a team that I never considered
for not one I didn't give them a single
look I didn't give him a third look if I
was doing a final four with the top four
most talented teams in the country LSU
is in that mix I put LSU in the top four
but something's been missing and when
you watch their offense still
something's missing you know I mean
obviously a great last drive by Etling
but they ran out of clock and you know
it probably could have managed the clock
also a little bit better as well on that
last drive but something's been missing
and I don't know what it is I don't know
if the edge was lost I don't know how it
happened but the talent has been in
Baton Rouge he's been getting these
these five star kids in Louisiana State
Louisiana high school there's no other
competition and that you saw the ESPN
300 last year no one had more talent
than Louisiana and they all go to LSU
because that's what they wanted to play
and you need to win at a high cliff on
you when you're at one of the best jobs
in the country but does he get good
quarterbacks he just doesn't develop
them or is he good at recruiting at any
other position but quarterback I think
the op I don't think that their
quarterbacks are put in a position to
succeed at all times I think they get
extremely conservative extremely vanilla
you look at their receivers both those
guys I bet you Malachi Dupre and shaving
door alleble you know top three round
picks in the NFL you know obviously for
net we know is one of those once in a
ten-year ties talents like Adrian
Peterson and I mean you need to be able
to find ways that he would whatever a
quarterback does well it might not be
they might not be the greatest passer
but you have to find ways to put him in
a position to succeed to make those
throws that he does feel comfortable
with and to adjust your system and I
mean the offenses has been extremely
predictable in Baton Rouge and it has it
been what it needs to be I mean you got
Odell green you have Dale Beckham jr.
several years ago you got Landry and
Jeremy Hill and all those guys in the
same backfield at the same time and you
had a little bit of success but you
should be putting up you know huge
numbers and should be a team that's
always high flying on often use David
[ __ ] from the mothership College
GameDay will be in Clemson South
Carolina coming up this weekend Clemson
and Louisville a game on ABC at eight
Eastern also college football live ESPN
tuesday through friday this week at
one-thirty how good a job
zillow issue is one of the top three
jobs in the country really I mean oh
absolutely and again to me Dan it's
about you don't recruit it you're the
kid to grow up in the state of Louisiana
again last year has the most the best
recruiting program in the country they
want to go to LSU they very rarely leave
the state Texas is right next door
you're going to be able to get guys from
Texas you're going to be able to get gas
from obviously from the southeast and
the traditional Southeastern Conference
footprint you know you look at the guys
they put in the league and that starts
to build on you know BB users they call
themselves and I mean you just look at
the talent on the roster and they got so
many NFL guys just up and down that are
that are literally on that roster it's
just I think it's definitely one of the
best jobs in the country and a job
that's the team that should be in the
hunt every year for the national title
yeah they have to play bama but they
shouldn't lose the bama four or five
times in a row that shouldn't have to
LSU the wish list for LSU should include
who Tom Herman Tom Herman and time again
then what do we want we always want the
opposite of what we had right they do on
exciting offensive football well Tom
Herman is one of the best offensive
coaches in all of football the way he
calls plays the way he designs it he's
got a hardcore tough mentality he is by
the way he's used to recruiting that
texas area right next door he's going to
lock down the state of Louisiana cuz
it's we know what it's going to be there
I mean it should it seems like it'd be a
great fit now here's the thing here's
the thing that was going to be annoying
LSU stands in to everybody else he
follows a sport if you fire les miles
and then you start going down to listen
and you don't have anybody in mind I
mean I think Jimbo Fisher's going to
come to mind because the ties to LSU but
this isn't a job for to me that you go
ok we're going to do a coordinator you
don't fire Les Miles I don't think for a
coordinate you got to go out and get
somebody one of these big names and I
think Tom Herman should be number one
number two and number three on the list
what about Lane Kiffin no absolutely not
absolutely not no I think lane kiffin is
a heck of an offensive coach no doubt
but from a standpoint of what he was
running the ship at USC and he was
making the decision he didn't do a good
job and now listen the one thing about
lane kiffin that you that you think
twice maybe he's been with the best in
the business we he's been with somebody
that knows how to run it as good as
anybody has ever run it in managed off
the field managed on the field one of
the best CEOs ever maybe that's rubbed
off on lane enough where he could do it
himself but I don't think Ella if I'm at
LSU I'm not sure I would make that move
yeah i agree with you what about art
briles ooh obviously we know he's the
antithesis offensively of what they just
had and he's a heck of a coach but I
mean I think all that stuff needs to be
settled first before you agree on art
browse you know I know he came out and
he did his apology and that was the next
step in the rehab of his rehabbing of
his career but I think you still need to
find out more that happened because
here's the thing you know this as well
as I do you don't fire great great great
coaches like Art Briles unless you did
something very egregious you find a way
to give people second and third chances
great players get second chances get
third chances great coaches are going to
get second chances and third chances
unless you do something that's really
really just you know that you can't put
up with and obviously that happened at
Baylor and that's that's something that
you got to think about when you when you
hire somebody and I'm our balls is a
great coach and I think you'll get
another opportunity I just don't know if
it's good to be an LSU USC situation
coach Helton safe I think he say for now
they've had so much turnover and maybe
they've had so much Austin so many ups
and downs and so many things that that
may spend like it's been like a reality
TV show there you know and it has it
changed with him and obviously this past
week it stinks when you got to come out
and answer allegations about one of your
players possibly punching you in the
face that's a little aggressive dammit
that's not fun but it is Hollywood and
it takes it to the right personality and
so far just seems like they haven't
found that the right comes for that [ __ ]
like you know listen to target replace
Pete Carroll and what he was able to
accomplish and his swagger but I don't
think he's out anytime soon you know
when Swansea ad now and we'll have to
see how that goes as well because he's
kind of new to the game too Brian Kelly
his situation at Notre Dame
well fun of the new DP well I'm just
talking about him cuz you can you can
blame you can pass the blame to others
but eventually it comes back to you yeah
but I think Brian Kelly's I think he's
earned it I don't think he's in any kind
of danger whatsoever i think the list
would be really long to get brian kelly
if somebody wanted to let go of him he's
somebody that you could look at and i
think he with the way he coaches offense
you could look at him with an LSU that
would be that would be a scary situation
to he's one of those guys that could go
there and I think have a ton of success
I if Notre Dame got rid of Brian Kelly I
think they'd be crazy David safe travels
thanks for joining us great stuff no
problem thank David Pauley ESPN College
GameDay the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience